hey morning oh that sir John Bercow has
proved rather pesky for the government
has an A in terms of bricks it what are
you gonna do now well the speaker has
raised the bar with his ruling yesterday
clearly that merits serious
consideration and we will discuss it as
you say at cabinet this morning we
always said that we in terms of bring in
a vote back for a third time we would
need to see a shift from
parliamentarians in terms of the support
I think that still is the case and we've
seen from the European Union that they
themselves see for example clarity on
any extension as a material issue for
the house to consider but obviously we
will discuss it this morning and take a
response from there so a lot of
discussions to be had on the quick
questions yesterday was legally can the
speaker do this if he explored that
option as to whether he's got a legal
right to do this well the speaker's the
referee and it's important that all of
us in the House of Commons respect the
role of the speaker the authority of the
chair but the speaker himself has
pointed to possible solutions he himself
has said in earlier rulings that we
shouldn't be bound by precedent and
obviously this is based on a precedent
going back to 1604 the speaker himself
has said that where the will of the
house is for a certain course of action
then it's important that that will of
the house is respected so it's important
we look at his previous rulings in the
context of yesterday's ruling as part of
taking our next step okay so you're
investigating his ruling to see what
your options are one of them that's been
discussed by your colleagues is
prolonging Parliament essentially ending
this session of Parliament and starting
another one earlier so you can put
forward your vote again it sounds very
complicated along winning what windy but
it is a possibility is that something
that you consider doing no I think the
the one thing for the divisions that
there are in the House of Commons at the
moment and all the divisions that there
are in the country on the brexit I think
the one thing everyone would agree on is
involving Her Majesty in any of the
issues around brakes it is not the way
forward so I don't see that as a
realistic option what we need to do is
secure the deal that's what business is
watching your program are crying out for
they want the certainty of the deal the
vast majority of people I speak to say
let's
just get on with this we've got a deal
it's the only deal on the table it's
taken over two years to negotiate so
let's get this deal agreed and we are
seeing significant movement from
colleagues me then because you keep
saying you have got this deal the
Speaker of the House has blocked you
from tabling it this week when will we
see it again you're saying it's not dead
in the water we are going to see it
again so when will that be is it the
case that the prime minister is going to
have to go and see EU representatives on
Thursday and ask for an extension well
we need to consider it obviously at
cabinet I think the ruling from the
speaker has raised the bar and I think
that makes it more unlikely that the
vote would be this week but we need to
consider that obviously the ruling was
only yesterday afternoon and covered so
when do you think we're likely to see it
next week well what the the speaker has
said in his ruling is that there needs
to be something that is different and
you can have the same motion but where
the circumstances have changed and
obviously that has a difference in terms
of how members of parliament would vote
on a particular motion so we need to
look at the detail of the ruling we need
to consider that in the context some
earlier rulings that okay that don't
particularly align with yesterday that
is something that the Speaker of the
House said he said you need to bring
this vote back to the house and it needs
to be different there needs to be
substantial change you can't just keep
bringing the same vote back so how are
you going to change it well the fact
that a number of members of parliament
have said that they will change their
vote points to the fact that there are
things that are different we're
obviously in discussions for example
with our confidence and supply partners
in the dup stovic is that crucial
well they are absolutely and their
confidence and supply and they've raised
issues in terms of the Union that we're
very keen to address so we need to look
at the issues around the extension we
need to look at the issues in terms of
parliamentarians or what reassurance
we've been able to give and whether that
passes the test that the speaker has set
in terms of what is different but you
can have the same motion but with
different circumstances around it and
the speaker himself accepts that point
because he allowed for the second
meaningful vote for exactly that reason
all right let's just talk about
extending article 50 because you know
signs are pointing to the fact that the
Prime Minister may well have to ask for
that and the
this week and it's important to ask you
in your role as brexit secretary because
there's a bizarre turn of events last
week when you wound up the debate on
extending article 54 the government
commending the motion to the house and
then you joined several other members of
cabinet in voting against it so where do
you stand on extending article 50 so we
can get this deal done
well I start with a prime minister which
is the best way forward is to get a deal
which will require now a short extension
and that is the best way or delivering
brexit but to clear at the point cuz
there was some confusion you're
absolutely right with my vote last
Thursday and it was the fourth vote it
was an amendable motion obviously we
needed to feet at the amendments the
entirety of my speech all but the last
line was on addressing those amendments
those amendments would have taken
control of the order paper which was a
threat both to brexit but also
constitutionally and it was right that
we addressed those obviously having done
so the purpose of the motion had been
served and it was also served because we
had committed to a further motion on the
25th of this month so here's a question
of being the fourth vote not the first
and all other reports suggested it was
the first fact again it's all sort of
higgledy-piggledy and tying everything
up in knots with different motions let's
be clear do you support an extension to
article 50 now at this moment well I do
have been clear that I don't want an
extension but we are now in a situation
where we do need to have an extension to
pass the legislation for the withdraw
bill because it's not just passing a
vote we then need to ratify that and
pass the legislation and there's not an
opportunity to do now that that's in the
remaining day so the world need to be a
short extension but I think what viewers
of this program will be saying is three
years after they voted for leave it
really is time now for members of
parliament to deliver on what many of
them said in their manifestos deliver on
the biggest vote in our country's
history but the prime ministers do on
the 29th of March the law says that now
as well are you ruling it out because
you've said that you're backing now an
extension to article 50 and that will
probably mean not leaving the EU on the
29th of March well it's not going to be
realistic to ratify because obviously
parliamentarians have blocked the
previous two votes but what's important
now
is we get a decision on the votes and on
the deal as soon as possible because I
think businesses need that certainty and
I think your viewers three years after
they voted to leave the European Union
want to see MPs deliver on what the
majority of them said they would do at
the last general election this is the
only deal on the table from the prime
minister she's taken over two years to
negotiate it the EU are clear is the
only deal on the table business need the
certainty of above this deal and it's
time that Parliament comes together and
gets behind it okay Stephen Barclay
breaks it secretary thank you for
speaking to us here on Sunrise